you're good I would talk about creating
a fighting style very much by any means
necessary throw glass in someone's face
kick them break their knees clutter
throats out
get them all my name's Pete Berg and I'm
gonna break down the fight scene in my
new movie mouth 22 and the infirmary of
American Embassy
so Eko has come to an American Embassy
as a police officer from the local
country that the embassies in and he's
seeking asylum the Americans are trying
to determine whether or not they can
trust him and if he is who he claims to
be so they're checking him out and they
check him out real good
that's when he goes best friends a
fellow Indonesia and fighter named Rama
who's developing quite a following of
his own when the first things I did with
eco and Rama was take them to a Garth
Brooks concert I bought em cowboy hats
Rama loves I got friends in low places
and actually go kicking Rama not a nice
thing to do to your friend everything
was real this is all real one of the
personalities of this fight whether you
go with my handcuff to the hospital bed
but what we talked about was separating
it from wire work and karate films that
have like really elegant beautiful moves
it's not meant to be particularly
Shelley is going to be brutal this fight
was seven days every day you know for
nine and ten hours in a very hot
warehouse in Atlanta these guys are
focused on doing this I did an interview
earlier today I talked to like Eastern
Promises I was inspired by that the
scene with Viggo Mortensen and esteem
when fights the two guys I think that's
one of the best fight seems of all time
you guys fight ass naked
and I kept showing he eco the fight and
told him that we're gonna do it like
that but I'm more frontal he was not
sure what to do I want to make of that
and walbrook was in on that and company
the Nightman eco you got guts to do that
full frontal nudity the whole fight see
amigo just get real quiet and we didn't
tell him - about a week before - he'd be
allowed to wear some underwear but he
was I think he was prepared to do it
coming up people doing their own stunts
ego gets thrown against a steel wall
there with obviously not a lot of
clothes on afterwards I could see his
backwards in purple and he did it three
or four times we're about to see you go
climb a wall this's his ideas like I'll
just go this way
finishing is very important in a fight
to the death
he's a big fan of Smashing pieces of
steel into someone's body and then
twisting it I was like what's with the
twist not enough to just smash him to
death he's like yes but this mean you
make sure you make sure there's making
sure right very twisted there we go
that's just to make sure
a really great experience for me getting
to work with something I consider be the
new wave of combat cinema a real
gentleman who would have done the scene
naked had he been asked so thank you so
much for watching the scene breakdown
watch mile 22 when it comes out please
August 17 you get your tickets on
Fandango thank you very much